l'entreprise américaine hbo ce pétrole
s'installe à montréal où elle va créer
150 emplois d'ici 2 ans boss pétrole a
développé un système de caméra
intelligente qui sont installés sur les
autobus scolaires et les conducteurs qui
ne respectent pas la loi sont identifiés
ils reçoivent une contravention et
d'ailleurs on en parle avec jean
soulière qui est pdg de bosses pétrole
bonjour monsieur soulière bonjour
olivier ça va très bien et vous oui très
très vite
on en parle beaucoup d'entreprises
j'imagine que cette bonne journée
aujourd'hui à une très bonne journée je
suis très content après avoir partie
d'entreprises aux etats-unis être
capable de ramener chez moi c'est
vraiment quelque chose de spécial
oui et là je voyais sur un site en
français parce qu'évidemment donc
l'entreprise au départ ces bosses
patrotte parce que le siège social est
situé en virginie
mais ici ce qu'on va dire bus patrouille
deux patrons et oui il exactement
alors qu'on a raison de dire c'est
également on a raison de dire de ce fait
rire parce que également vous le dire il
ya plusieurs québécois va le projet
alors vous que pdg
c'est une aventure québécois tout seul
oui mais cc c'est vraiment des moins
mais mes collègues des investisseurs des
technologues québécois qui ont découvert
accidentellement travers un ami qui
avait des dépassements illégaux sur des
autobus scolaires arrêté on a vu
l'envergure du programme du problème
mais on a développé des systèmes des
logiciels à travers des acquisitions
on a perdu une entreprise qu'on a
commencé à opérer en 2017
et maintenant on se retrouve les chefs
de file d'une industrie qu'on a pas mal
crée alors c'est c'est vraiment une
belle histoire
expliquez moi alors vous équiper donc
les autobus avec une technologie qui
permet de détecter les automobilistes
qui ne respectent pas vous savez l'arrêt
obligatoire lorsque le panneau a
réactivé sur l'autobus
alors c'est soit le point de départ oui
c'est bien ça on a l'intelligence
artificielle qui est capable de
déterminer si des véhicules départ si
les galvanise de bus scolaire jusqu'à
huit voix de distance c'est oui ces
filles ont droit à huit voix lui de voix
des deux directions on est capable
d'attraper les véhicules ont une
résolution de 4 cas sur nos caméras
vraiment c'est un système qui attrape
tout le monde alors on est capable à
travers un déploiement sur les flottes
entières d'autobus scolaires changé et
réduire les dépassements parce que une
fois que les citoyens comprennent bien
que chaque de bus scolaire dans leur
communauté est équipé avec une
technologie comme la note ils vont
penser deux fois avant de dépenser
l'autobus scolaire et ça va rendre la
vie plus sécuritaire pour les enfants
oui exactement écuries peuvent se faire
pincer toujours parce que évidemment si
les autobus scolaires autour cette
petite caméra là alors là ça françois
que ce serait différent et vous générez
faut le dire la preuve de l'infraction
et après que vous allez travailler de
concert avec la police et les
municipalités
oui absolument ce partenariat avec les
villes et les services policiers et les
écoles nous aurons produit la preuve on
en voit la preuve automatiquement aux
services policiers qui eux détermine
c'est une infraction ou pas une fois que
l'infraction elle était mise nous on
s'occupe de tout l'arrière plan alors
l'impression de la contravention on
envoie la contravention mais on donne
accès aux vidéos aux preuves que au
personnes qui dépassent pour que les
autres puissent voir leur vie et psys
également et et ça les motive et ça les
éduque pis aller ça lui fait penser deux
fois avant de leur faire évidemment donc
très bons procédés
alors là ya pas de frais d'implantation
je lisais ce matin pour les
municipalités et vous vous payez avec
une partie des revenus de la
contravention mais je trouvais qu'il y
avait quelque chose d'un peu de
paradoxal là dedans parce que vous savez
on veut en général moins d'infractions a
envie que ça se produit ça mais vous
générez vous revenez avec les
contraventions
c'est un beau projet axé sur la sécurité
c'est vraiment ce qui était là la
philosophie de base de notre entreprise
quand on a vu l'envergure du problème
est le nombre de fois que les autobus
sont dépassés et on voit aussi des
nouveaux conducteurs à tous les ans on
voit des gens qui rentrent et qui
sortent des villes alors l'opportunité
d'éduquer les gens n'arrêtent jamais une
fois qu'on connaît que l'autobus
scolaire et au cloud et qu'on est
capable d'automatiser plein de choses
mais on a aussi d'autres produits et
d'autres services à offrir
alors on veut vraiment
un moderniser l'infrastructure
technologique qui existent sur les
autobus scolaires parce que on est du on
est vraiment dû de faire en sorte qu'il
ya une évolution comme on voit dans nos
voitures dans les autobus scolaires
c'est notre futur qui en a qui
embarquent sur des autobus est là et les
périls qui font faire ça tous les jours
avec les gens qui portent peut-être
moins attention à cause de la
technologie pas qu'on peut servir de la
technologie poe pour les arrêter et
faire changer
l'avocat de l'information vous voulez
que je sois aussi donc une avant un truc
soit rentable il ya déjà cinquante mille
autobus qui ont votre petit dispositif
j'imagine que c'est surtout aux états
unis à l'heure actuelle mais sait on pas
encore c'est d'ici la fin de l'année on
va avoir 50 milles de déployer mais
c'est pas un petit dispositif c'est
quand même une suite technologique on a
une boîte de caméras sur le côté et tout
ce qui vient avec pour la connecter on
est connecté avec les services amazon et
aussi les services cellulaires d'une
façon pas mal cool oui et je regardais
aussi le marché parce que le quoi si la
fin d'année
l'autobus maury total je regardais le
marché ces cinq fermes et l'autobus 550
550 minutes aux us aux états unis et au
canada
alors on vient juste de dons de percée
de partir le marché mais l'europe side
10 on y est énorme alors on nous autres
on croit avoir une entreprise qui va
croire d'une façon assez importante très
très rapidement ils ont le devis j'ai eu
une aventure avec beaucoup de québécois
je fais tout normal de revenir à
montréal
oui mais aussi avec la main d'oeuvre
qualifiée ici bilingue avec le
l'expérience dans le développement des
systèmes d'intelligence artificielle
aussi on avait un besoin des bergers des
centres de preuve au canada pour pouvoir
exploiter le marché canadien
récemment on a signé une entente avec la
firme hypertec qui va nous aider dans le
manufacturing de nos produits et on va
devenir aussi un exportateur de
technologies aux etats-unis et peut-être
à travers le monde dont on ne sait
jamais nous autres notre rêve continue à
grossir à tous les jours le potentiel
100 m on vous souhaite un bon succès
jean souliers à merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous
merci bonne soirée